Grand Theft Auto 6. It's been 12 years
since Grand Theft Auto 5 came out. And
that game is actually in the top three
of most sold ever. Um the top three is
Minecraft, Grand Theft Auto 5, and
Tetris. Now whether which one is like
the best one considering it depends on
what um statistics you look at, but
basically Tetris has uh been sold over
520 million times. Minecraft 350 million
and Grand Theft Auto 5 210 million
times. Wow. Wow. So, the trailer that
just dropped 88 million views in a
couple of days, but um so that's a big
deal for a video game. It's really sad
that we don't have like some Christian
that has that kind of numbers. Mhm. You
know what I mean? Can you imagine if
some I I wonder what is the top
Christian viewed thing out there? Do you
do you even know like a guess? The
chosen probably probably The chosen.
Yeah, that's true. It's just a drop in
the bucket compared to this. Yeah. Yeah,
it's true. By the way, we have a
documentary on The Chosen on our
channel. You should check it out. We'll
put a link in the description. Um, but
so yeah, Grand Theft Auto 6, I want to
talk about a little bit because, you
know, we are a Christian channel and we
want to look at these things through the
lens of the Bible. And um it's it's
interesting how you know because Grand
Theft Auto is such a big genre, there's
always been these questions that people
have, right, about Grand Theft Auto and
like should Christians be watching it?
You see a lot of Christian YouTubers and
commentators asking those questions. But
first, let's look at the story of Grand
Theft Auto 6. So basically, Grand Theft
Auto 6 has a couple in there. It's the
first female protagonist ever in the
series. So, it's about Lucia Caminos and
Jason Duval. It will happen in Vice
City, which we've also seen in a 2002
Grand Theft Auto, which is basically
like a duplicate of Miami. Just they
just changed the names up a little bit,
but it's uh kind of giving off those
vibes. So when you look at what's being
publicized about Grand Theft Auto 6 and
what we know about the storyline so far
based on, you know, leaks and the
trailer and stuff, you can see that
Jason Duval and Lucia Cambinos, there
are basically considered Bonnie and
Clyde by all of the media. That's just
how they describe them. And I find that
pretty interesting. And especially here
if you look at the bottom of the first
paragraph, it says um some of their
lower stake crime goes further south and
lands the couple in major criminal
territory. So this is obviously about
crime, right? But how that lands the
couple in a criminal conspiracy
stretching across the state of Leonita
is still a big mystery. So and now he's
talking about the GTA characters, right?
GTA characters. Yes. Yes. The couple. So
we know this is about crime. It's Grand
Theft Auto. Keith, what does Grand Theft
Auto mean? We were discussing it the
other day. What's the essence of it? I
think it depends a little bit on what
state you're in, how they define it.
Some states are, you know, it has to be
a goal a vehicle that's $1,000 or more,
which almost any vehicle qualifies for
that anymore. So, but other other
places, I don't think it matters. It's
just any motor vehicle that's stolen.
Yeah. So, to add to that, I did actually
play Grand Theft Auto when I was
younger. I wasn't always a Christian and
uh my you know I was heavily into video
games when I was younger like Halo and
you know Call of Duty and Need for Speed
and all those things and did some online
gaming as well and and Grand Theft Auto
is something I also played and uh yeah I
stole a lot of cars you know um thought
it was the coolest thing and like to
play the missions and all that stuff and
but I played uh I think the first one I
played was San Andreas and then I played
Grand Theft Auto 4 And then I was like,
I don't think I want to keep doing this.
But anyway, um, Bonnie and Clyde, you
know, they were real people. Another
couple that was were living in the 1930s
and they were a crime couple basically
and they're very romanticized by
American folklore. Um, but uh, yeah,
they're pretty bad people. FBI, it talks
about it. They met in Texas in the
1930s. Uh she was 19 and married to an
imprisoned murderer and Clyde was 21 and
unmarried and soon after he was arrested
for a burglary and sent to jail. He
escaped using a gun Bonnie had smuggled
to him was recaptured and was sent back
to prison and Clyde was parrolled in
February 1932, rejoined Bonnie and
resumed a life of crime. So this is the
couple that this video game couple is
being compared to. Okay, so let's look
at a couple more characters that are in
the video game um that are going to end
up in Vice City. A few ones that are
interesting is Drecoon Priest. He is an
artist looking to move on from drug
dealing and into music. So, uh you know,
drugs are obviously a big part of the
video game and smoking and and those
kind of things. And also Raul Batista,
he's a bank robber with a storied rap
sheet. So, there you go. And you see a
couple pictures here. I had to blur them
because there's just ladies on the
street posing with a dude taking a
picture and everything is hanging out.
Oh my. They're covered, but everything
is hanging out. I'm not sure why they're
doing that, but you can see it's all
about violence and sex and nudity and
fast cars and drugs basically. So, this
is what the game is about. And also the
fact that they call the city Vice City.
When I was younger, because I grew up in
the Netherlands, I didn't know what the
word vice meant. I didn't know because I
wasn't famili that familiar with English
yet. And now I know. And I'm like, "Oh,
that's interesting." Yeah. What does
vice mean? Vice means like like like
something you're addicted to or struggle
with or it's like your your your thing
if you do drugs or you're addict to.
It's a vice like something that holds
you. Yeah. I see. Interesting. Yeah. I
think it's fascinating that in 2013 you
have one that comes out and then
you have a whole new group that's
probably getting ready to play this or
old enough to play it that wasn't old
enough to play the last one. Mhm. But
the ones that played the last one will
also play the new one. Yeah, sure they
will. And I'm sure people go back and
and probably play other ones. But it's
so strange because here's a game. It's
named after a crime. How many other
games do you think would fly if they
were named after a crime? Right. It's It
was surprisingly if there's a lot of
kids I mean how old were you when you
were playing this game? I bought Well,
San Andreas probably like 12, 13. And so
your parents ever know about it? And
yeah, my my mom knew. Um you know, she
would walk into my room sometimes and
you know, she knew and she would say,
"Don't do that." But, you know, we kids
know how to hide stuff, right? So, I
just like found ways to do it in secret,
like maybe stay up late at night when
everybody goes to bed kind of a thing.
But, uh, yeah, it's not something that
they appreciated. And my mom wasn't a
Christian at the time, but had been
grown up with Christian principles, so
that was still like, you know, was
there. I think that people don't put
those two things together like um it
obviously being a form of entertainment
and you know kids are just doing it
thinking like oh well I'm not really
actually doing that thing I'm just you
know playing a game but you're
consciously making those decisions for
that player to do those things. You're
desiring that that player either steals
that car or shoots that person or you're
the one that's making that decision. I
think it's a little different than than
like watching movies or television where
you're sort of passively you can't
control the thing. You're not going to
change the story. Um but this you you
are it's almost like blurring that line
one step further. There was a professor
um he was at BI BYU I don't know if he
still is and I forget his name but we
should link to this video. He actually
had a series of five videos that was BYU
social sciences and they were all about
violence and video games. And he made a
pretty significant
claim. He said the link the only link
more established in
science than video games correlating
with violence was smoking and
cigarettes.
the the more what was what was it that
was uh the correlated with there's a
there is a correlation between video
games and
violence the only link that he sees
stronger in science was the link between
smoking cigarettes and cancer
interesting link is very strong yeah and
and he doesn't take you know he's he he
does a very good job at showing like
just because you play a violent video
game doesn't mean I think you're going
to go out and be the next Coline shooter
Most people know that that's not going
to happen. That's not realistic. It's
it's a very small percentage. His angle
is what I want to know is how do you
treat your brothers and sisters at home?
How do you treat your parents? How do
you treat the people around you? and
he's done studies with I think with his
team and and looked at other studies and
there is a demonstrable correlation
between behavior and violent video
games. Not that you're going to murder
somebody, but just your overall
behavior. I think you're you're
preparing the way. I mean, you know, if
you if you look back on the Holocaust,
you know, they heavily used propaganda
to move the people into a state that
they would do harmful things to someone
else. And I feel like like the
groundwork around the world is being
laid right now. Yes, nobody's maybe
acting on those things, but if the
circumstances went that direction, I
could easily see you've got a primed
pump of people like that are
desensitized to this kind of violence,
you know. Yeah. that and you have all
kinds of video games that are like, you
know, teaching violence, Mortal Kombat
type stuff, Street Fighter, Call of
Duty, you know, all that kind of stuff.
It's designed to just teach people to
take life or beat somebody to a pulp.
And do you guys remember um we on the
last one that we did about the video
games, we showed the the guy that wrote
the book on how to take healthy people
and and have them point a gun. and he
works with the military and with the
police officers because we all have this
preservation of life in it's like a it's
like a safety mechanism in your body.
It's very difficult to point a gun at
somebody and actually shoot them. And um
they would have to train cops how to do
that because they don't want you
hesitating if you're in a dangerous
situation. And what struck me about that
was he was saying how we train cops or
how we train military people to do that
is we shoot targets that look like
humans. That look like humans. Yeah. And
so that's that's breaking down that
barrier inside of you and and I mean
what did what are you doing here? You're
you're doing harmful things to humans
like sure that's got to break down your
barriers at some level. Good point.
Yeah. And then also we discussed this
many times but the the scientific
evidence for mirror neurons right monkey
see monkey do. So, um, it was it was
discovered in a in a lab in Italy where
I kind of forgot what kind of a monkey
it was, but basically they were testing
the neurons of the monkey and as the
scientist was eating like peanuts or
something like that, the neuron fired in
his brain a mirror neuron that as if the
pe a monkey was eating the peanuts, but
he wasn't actually eating the peanuts.
And I found out that people have the
same kind of mirror neurons that um, you
know, if I'm this and this applies to
movies, too. If I'm watching a movie and
I'm seeing somebody shoot somebody, that
means that my brain can't tell the
difference. But how even more so, like
you're saying in the video game when you
are um making the decisions for the
person, you are literally put like if
you don't press any keys, he will just
stand there, but if he press forward, he
will walk. And if you make him shoot a
person, the person is shot. You are
doing that. And you have the mirror
neurons. Mhm. So that's pretty
fascinating and the Bible talks about
this. Um it talks about how um by
beholding Christ as in a mirror, we will
become more like Christ. But if we
behold that you can take that concept
the other way as well. Like if we behold
evil, of course we'll become more like
evil. I always, you know, when I talk to
audiences, I always tell them you take
something like Fortnite. I have a video
on that, too. But if you took something
like Fortnite, people are looking at us
just cartoon characters. It doesn't look
like real blood. But the whole object,
everybody will admit, is you have to off
everybody. You have to kill everybody to
win. I'm like, well, what if you change
the characters? What if they're not
random people? What if they're your
relatives? Mhm. Got a problem with that?
Could you go into a video games and off
your relatives if they look like people
you know and love and care about or your
friends? Take it a step further. What if
it was, you know, little kids or
babies? I mean, would you feel
comfortable doing that in a video game?
Would that bother you? Mhm. I mean, it
bother me.
What if you change the goal? What if
it's now the goal is not killing people,
but it's cheating on your spouse?
How's that different than pornography?
You know, it's a short walk. Yeah. Yeah.
And the US military uses stuff like that
to train people. So why would they do it
if it didn't work? The Bible actually um
I think illustrates this. We we've
brought Romans 1:32 up a lot of times
when we're when we're discussing these
kind of topics. And you know it says um
knowing the judgment of God, they which
commit such things are worthy of the
judgment, but not only do the same, but
take pleasure in them that do that. and
and that that means that like if
somebody's doing these heinous crimes
like they're in danger of the judgment
of of of paying the penalty for that
crime, but also Paul illustrates that
and says, "But the people that are
taking pleasure in them doing that are
actually accounted as if they were doing
it themselves." And so, you know, I
think that really sets the the the field
in a in an interesting light if people
ask like, "Hey, can Christians play this
game?"
I mean, you know, if you could honestly
say, you know, I could play this game
with Jesus, you know, and we'd be
playing together. If you could really
probably think that through and, you
know, you'd probably come to the
conclusion that no, Jesus would not be
sitting here stealing cars and and doing
things that that, you know, caused him
to come down and and and leave the the
comforts of heaven to come and die for
us. That's right. He's not going to
glorify the thing that brought him down.
Mhm. Mhm. I guess that raises the
question, is it a sin to play a game
like GTA? Well, on Reddit, there was
actually somebody who asked that
question. They said that they're a new
believer. Um, they got to get to know
the Lord Jesus a year ago in
2023. And he said, "I often play GJ GTA
5 because I was bored, but in the game I
go murder people committing a sin." So,
he called it a sin. He recognizes as
such that is a sin in real life. It was
the point for of the game. That's why it
is called Grand Theft Auto. I was
wondering, is it a sin for playing Grand
Theft Auto? So, it is in a subreddit
called Christian. Majority of people on
the subreddit actually answered against
playing Grand Theft Auto. They said,
"Yeah, this is not okay." Which I
actually was quite surprised by and
that's I'm glad. So, somebody said,
"Would you invite Jesus over to play
with you like like you said? We can be
sure the Holy Spirit hates it.
Does it glorify
God? It is pretty dark. A pretty dark
game. I was excited to get it. Get get
it and play. Then the opening scene had
you killing cops. Yeah, I don't think
it's very Christian at
all. Somebody said, "Pretty sure it is
like it is a sin. You commit crimes and
sex with its story and minions." And
then the person responds, "It's just a
game. It's fiction. No real crime was
committed." So, we can go into that a
little bit deeper of how the B Bible
views those kind of things of like is
we've already talked about the the the
seeing something is also doing
something, but the Bible has something
more to say about that as well. But, uh
yeah, somebody says probably it's a
murder simulator. Wow, that's pretty
strong language. And then this person
actually quoted Philippians 4:8 that
says we should um meditate in whatever
things are true,
whe pure, lovely, of good report. If
there's any virtue and if there's
anything praiseworthy, meditate on these
things. He says, "I don't think GTA
falls under these instructions. Best not
to spend a lot of time selling drugs and
running people over in a video game."
But then this person came in. You were
not actually committing any sin. So, no.
And I think that what the person is
coming from is that well, you're in a
game. And again, like that person said,
it's fiction, so therefore it's not a
sin as long as you don't do it in real
life. I want to look at the question
that the original person asked, is it a
sin to play Grand Theft Auto? So, for us
to answer that as Christians, we should
go to the Bible, right? And the Bible
actually has a definition of what sin
is. And we can find in 1 John
3:4. Whosoever committh a sin
transgresseth also the law, for sin is
the transgression of the law. For by the
law is the knowledge of sin. So, and
there's actually another Bible verse as
well that talks about how the law is
like a mirror that we look into that
basically shows us our sin. So, if I'm
filthy, because sin is is filthy, right?
I have a spot on my face. I look in the
mirror, I'm like, "Oh, that's what the
law does. It shows you that you have a
problem, but it doesn't take away the
problem. That's Jesus. He cleanses us
with his blood." Yeah. I mean, I if if
it's breaking of the law, you know,
you're certainly teetering close to
something where that's the object of the
game is to break the laws. I mean, we
have laws in this country. You can't
kill people, steal from them, and run
people over. I mean, that's not that's
not even a religious thing. That's just
like we have laws in this country not to
do those things. Well, I I I find it
interesting that you bring that up about
our country's laws because our country
mostly was based on laws from that are
found in the Bible, right? And we can
find them in the Bible still. Exodus
20:13, thou shalt not kill. Is this part
of Grand Theft Auto? Yes. And is it part
of the American law? Yes.
Exodus 20:14, "Thou shalt not commit
adultery." Man, Grand Theft Auto is full
of I mean, you can see this in the
trailer of Grand Theft Auto 6 about all
these like prostitutes waving to the
main character like, "Hey, like he knew
them and had like been probably been
visiting them. Um, he's definitely not
married when he's sleeping around with
his with his girlfriend." I'm pretty
sure you as a player, you can also go
and sleep around, which is weird that
you have the option to do that in a
game. Well, it's also weird someone to
sleep with them. Probably he I mean the
main characters are together, but then
like as the characters you can also go
and off with prostitutes like okay, very
strange. Uh Exodus 20:15, thou shalt not
steal grand theft auto. I've stolen
plenty of cars in that game. And then
Exodus 2016, thou shalt not bear false
witness against thy neighbor. Don't lie.
Don't tell a lie about this other person
that's not true. I bet you that also
happens in the
game. So I want to ask you guys this
question,
right? Kind of playing devil's advocate
here.
If sin is the transgression of the law,
like so meaning if you break God's ten
commandments, that equates to
sin. Then yes, playing Grand Theft Auto
is a sin, right?
But what if the law has been done away
with? Because a lot of Christians, we
don't believe that the law has been done
away with. We believe it's valid. But a
lot of Christians believe the law has
been done away with. Using texts like
Romans 6:14, for sin shall not have
dominion over you, for you are not under
the law, but under grace. And we'll
explain this in just a second. But if
you believe that and you believe we're
no longer under the law because we're
under grace and there is no more law,
then you can play Grand Theft Auto. I
think there needs to be a distinction in
in Christianity. Like what is that law?
There was a law in heaven. That's what
Satan was basically rebelling against,
right? Didn't want to honor God as the
supreme ruler. And um you know they they
must have understood the law in some
way, shape or form. And and does that
make any sense that that God would say,
"Oh, it doesn't matter about the law
anymore." I mean, this is the very
foundational structure of how heaven is
heaven. People aren't sitting there
doing bad things to each other. So, you
know, the angels we know are holy and
lawabiding angels. I think you're going
to run yourself into a lot of circles
because if the law is done away with
what do you do with texts that say a new
commandment I give to you that you love
one
another. Is that loving? Yeah. No.
I mean
so where does that put you? You know,
and interesting thing about that text in
particular in the Greek, there's two
words for
new. One word is neos, which means new,
brand new. It's the prefix we use for
things like neonatal unit, brand new
born babies, right? Um, neolithic,
things like that. That's not the word
that's used. The word that's used there
in the Greek is the word kinos, which is
new but renewed. In other words, it
already existed before. It's being put
to you in a new light. So when Jesus
says, "A new commandment I give to you,"
he's not saying, "I'm making up
something totally new," he's saying,
"No, no, no. This idea has already
existed. I'm expounding upon this. It's
not like a totally new thing, right? I
mean, I think most Christians, if you
really sit down and have a conversation
with them, they wouldn't believe that
you can now steal and kill and cheat and
lie and, you know, have other gods
before you." I think the the the general
consensus coming from Christianity is
like, yeah, yeah, you still need those.
And then what does that say about well
in Christianity that's done away with,
but in our government it's there like
like it doesn't make sense. It doesn't
make any sense. No, the Bible's pretty
pretty clear even in the New Testament
and people like to say that's all just
an Old Testament Jewish thing. No, Jesus
taught in the New Testament that, you
know, not one jot, not one tit is going
to pass from the law. And and yeah, you
know, if you love me, keep my
commandments. You have Revelation 22,
which is written after the time of
Jesus. Blessed are those who do his
commandments that they may have right to
the tree of life. Yeah. So, what here's
the here's the patience of the saints.
The they're they that, you know, keep
the commandments of God and have the
testimony of Jesus. And what
commandments? And after that it's
saying, you know, or it's saying these
are the people that aren't going to
enter, liars andorc, you know, murderers
and sorcerers and things like that. So
clearly it's talking about the same
kinds of things. Yeah. Well, I and I
like the the concept you brought up
about Satan, right? Like he sinned and
rebelled. Like we know in Isaiah Ezekiel
28 and Isaiah 14, he was holy. He wanted
to be greater than God. So you could say
he definitely broke the commandment of
thou shalt not make other gods before me
because he made himself a god. Basically
he worshiped himself. So you know think
about it. First of all if Satan if there
was no law then there is no sin right?
So then why could God kick Satan out if
there's no law? Okay so maybe in the Old
Testament there was a law. But then how
about when Jesus comes back and um he's
going to say, "Hey, yes, I'm back and
we're going to finally destroy Satan,
which is biblical. Sin is going to end."
But but what do you mean? There's no
more sin, right? Because there's no more
law. And then like, well, how can Satan
then be held accountable if there is no
more sin to define you have done this
and therefore this is your punishment?
Because what is sin is a transgression
of the law. It's the same in a in a
courthouse. You say, "You, sir, have
committed a crime. How do I know you've
committed a crime?" Well, you've broken
the law. Therefore, this is your crime.
God has the same standard of judgment.
You've broken the law. Therefore, you
have sinned and this is the result of
sin. Yes. And just like in law, when you
commit a crime, like if I hit him, punch
him in the
nose and he forgives me. Now I'm under
grace. I don't go and hit him again
somewhere else and say, "Well, I'm under
grace, so anything I do doesn't matter
now. I can I can do whatever I want to
you." That we it's not even logical. And
then, you know, the Bible explains
itself. So Romans 6:14 where it says um
sin shall have no not dominion over you
for you are not under the law but under
grace. Romans 8:1 says there is
therefore now no condemnation to them
which are in Christ Jesus who walk not
after the flesh but after the spirit. So
this explains it. It basically means if
I am driving in my car and the speed
limit is
55, am I being condemned by the law? No.
But does it mean there is no law? Yes,
there is. There is a law. But because
I'm not speeding, I'm not being
condemned by the law. And so Jesus, he
is in us and he helps us overcome sin.
And as a result of that, the law cannot
condemn us in those portions where he's
given me the victory. Right? That's
basically what it's saying. Now, and the
Bible also even explains what it means
to um walk not after the flesh, but
after the spirit. It explains it in
Ezekiel 36. It says, "A new heart also
will I give you, and a new spirit will I
put within you, and I will take away the
stony heart out of your flesh, and I
will give you a heart of flesh, and I
will put my spirit within you, and cause
you to walk in my statutes, and you
shall keep my judgments and do them."
Now, how do we know that statutes,
judgments, that this is a reference to
the commandments? When you look at
Exodus 21:1, it says, "Now these are the
judgments which you shall set before
them." So this is Exodus 21:1. But what
follows in the rest of the chapter 21,
222, 23 are basically specific legal
cases applying principles like do not
kill, do not steal, honor your parents,
etc. So it's expounding on the law. And
you see the same thing in Deuteronomy
5:1 where it says, "Hear, O Israel, the
statutes and judgments which I speak in
your hearing today that you may learn
them and be careful to observe them.
observe them. But then it says this
right before repeating the ten
commandments in Deuteronomy 5
6-21. So basically the statutes and the
judgments again is expounding on the ten
commandments. It's explaining it more of
what it looks like to keep the ten
commandments. This is one of my actual
favorite verses because um I think when
you start to deal with um keeping the
law or um you know doing things that God
said there's there's going to be no
doubt some people that are like oh you
legalists you guys are just wanting to
work your way to heaven. And uh that's
not what this verse says right here. I
mean I love how it starts. A new heart
also will I give you. That's not you
getting a new your own heart and making
your own things happen. This is God
promising that when you ask him to
create in you a clean heart or renew a
right spirit, this is his answer. He's
like, I will I will put this inside of
you. And I love that it says, I will
cause you to walk in my statutes and
judgments. It's God doing it in me. It's
God doing them. And so so anybody that
thinks like, oh, you know, you guys are
just wanting to work your way to heaven.
No, that's that's not what this this
verse is talking about at all. It's
submitting to God and letting him work
his ways in our life. And it's through
God's word. And if you look at this in a
greater context, God is starting with
the heart here. But what follows next is
Ezekiel 37, which is a valley of dry
bones, which is God's word being spoken
because he says prophesy, right? And out
of that doesn't just come the heart, it
comes the whole body. God is going
through a process of transformation and
renewal. Yeah. So I find it fascinating
that Romans talks about um there's no
condemnation to them which are in Christ
Jesus, right? Like if you walk in me,
you are no you are not sinning at that
moment. Like you are your heart's being
changed and being transformed and giving
a new heart. There's no condemnation for
those who who walk not after the flesh
but after the spirit. And the way he
explains that is, I'm going to do this
work in you and I'm going to help you to
do what? To keep my commandments by me
giving you a new heart. That doesn't
mean that overnight I am sinless. Like
overnight I'm like, I'm good. I I don't
no longer sin, right? It's a constant
surrender to Jesus and saying, Lord,
would you please help me? I see the
beauty in what you're wanting to do in
my heart and you've given these
commandments. First four are all about
loving God. And the last six are all
about loving man. That's beautiful. Help
me, Lord, to become more like you, to
love you and love man the way you've
asked me, told me to do. That's what he
wants to do. And that's what it's
talking about. If Paul had a problem
with the commandments, he probably
wouldn't have said in Romans 7:12,
"Therefore, the law is holy and the
commandment holy and just and good." He
doesn't have a problem with God's law.
Mhm. Right. That's right. Right. So,
going back to Romans 6:14, the verse
where it says, "For sin shall have no
dominion over you, for you are not under
the law, but under grace." If you look
in the exact same chapter and just go a
couple verses back, this is what Paul
says. What shall we say then? Shall we
continue in sin that grace may abound?
So in other words, you know, um we have
grace. So therefore, shall we just sin
like nothing else just because we've
been gi given grace? Absolutely not. In
other words, because we have grace,
shall we therefore sin, aka break God's
commandments? No. It says, um, God
forbid, how shall we that are dead to
sin live any longer therein? Know he not
that so many of us as were baptized into
Jesus Christ were baptized into his
death. Therefore we are buried with him
by baptism into his death that like as
Christ was raised up from the dead by
the glory of the father even so we also
should walk in the newness of life. In
other words, do as Jesus did. Jesus died
and rose again. And your baptism is a
symbol of laying out down your old life.
And as Paul talks about becoming a new
creature in Jesus, do as Jesus did. And
Jesus lived a sinless life. He came to
die for us and live the sinless life.
And he even actually says in a couple
verses, "Go and sin no more." He's like,
"I don't want you to sin anymore because
I came to save you from sin. So follow
me. I will give you the strength. I'll
give you the victory over your sins." Is
it Jude that says to him who is able to
keep you from falling? Why would you
make a statement like that if God can't
keep you from falling? You know what I
mean? And it's like I think uh um I like
to just take something in my personal
life and try to equate this with
something like uh I used to do and I
don't no longer do. I mean is it
possible to stop smoking cigarettes?
Absolutely. Somebody can stop. They can
have victory over that. And so you know
if you if you look at it like this is
God trying to basically
have us be buried, be dead. We're dead
to sin. It's no longer me that's living.
It's Jesus that lives in me and he's the
one that's doing all these things.
That's where the the confusion I think
becomes is people are just like, "Well,
your effort's going to try to produce
this. There's nothing we can do to make
this happen. This is a a gift from God,
but it's a surrendering and letting God
work through you in your life to
overcome these things." And the Bible is
also very clear that Jesus is
interceding for us right now. But in
what would he need to intercede for us
for, right? The Bible says that you know
if we sin, he is faithful and just to
cleanse us from all unrighteousness. But
how from what unrighteousness are being
cleansed if there is no sin to commit
anymore, right? Right. So it's pretty
clear that even after Jesus died, he is
still working in us to stop sinning.
Amen. And why would he say in the very
end in Revelation like to him um uh let
those that are holy be holy still and
let those that are wicked be wicked
still. There's a difference between the
two classes, you know. So Hebrews also
talks about the new covenant. For this
is the covenant that I will make with
you your h the house of Israel after
those days says the Lord. I will put my
laws in their mind and write them on
their hearts and I will be their God and
they shall be my people. And this is
actually Paul quoting from the Old
Testament. Um, so this is the new
covenant. God says, "I want to put my
law in your heart. So again, it's not
like you're carrying some burden. It's
like I want to transform you. I want to
change you. I want to make you more like
me." And what is God? God is love. What
are the ten commandments about? They're
all about loving God and loving man.
Colossians 2:14. So this is a verse that
is frequently used by people to say,
"Well, the ten commandments were nailed
to the cross." But is that actually what
this verse is saying? Blotting out the
handwriting of ordinances that was
against us, which was contrary to us,
and took it out of the way, nailing it
to his cross. Keith, what are these
ordinances?
So the out there were some things that
Moses wrote that had to do with the
ceremonial law that were kept uh in a in
a scroll on the outside of the ark of
the covenant. Those are the handwriting
of ordinances. Um it's referred to that
way because it's this is a man-made
document. It's written by man. It's not
written by the finger of God. The rocks
on the inside would were written by God
himself in stone.
So there's a distinction there in
material and the person who inscribed
them. And so it's referring to these
things that were written ceremonial law.
And and with that came
um things that were written against them
like if they didn't perform those
things. Think of it like blessings and
curses. Um but they were on the outside.
They weren't on the inside. And over
time, those things do not apply anymore
because they had to do with a a system
that was built on rights and rituals and
pointed to Christ coming, the Messiah.
And he came, he fulfilled those things.
They don't apply anymore. So, that's
what was essentially nailed to the
cross. Yeah. Because in the Old
Testament, all of those uh festivals and
holidays and ceremonies, they were all
just symbolically pointing to the
Messiah. It was to teach the Jews and
Israelites about the coming Messiah. And
then Jesus came and he was the
fulfillment of that symbol. It wasn't
necessary anymore because now he was the
real life symbol. He had come and he had
died. And what does that say? If you
continue on those symbols, yeah, after
Jesus already came, if it's looking
forward to a time that Jesus has come,
is that a rejection of Jesus basically
and then we're waiting for a new Messiah
to show up? Yeah. So, so that's why they
had to cease. And we see this also in
Ephesians
2:14. So this also talks about the
ordinances for he himself is our peace
who has made both one and has broken
down the middle wall of separation
having abolished in his flesh the enmity
that is the law of the commandments
contained in the ordinances. It's not
talking about the ten commandments. It's
saying again the ordinances but it's
talking about the middle wall of
separation. Where do we see that? Where
did this happen? Matthew 27. And Jesus
cried out against again with a loud
voice and yielded up his spirit. Then
behold, the veil of the temple was torn
in two from top to bottom and the earth
quaked and the rocks were split. So you
can see both in the Ephesians and in
Matthew, this is where the ordinances
were stopped because Jesus who was the
lamb of God as John called him, John the
Baptist in John, the book of John, um he
was that symbol of the lamb in the Old
Testament in the tabernacle in the
sanctuary that was going to be the
spotless lamb that's going to be slain.
And now Jesus would died, the true lamb
of God died. And this veil in the temple
in the most holy place where these
ordinances happened tore into right now
you could look into the most holy place.
So um and then Jesus let's look a couple
Jesus' words what he said about the law
when he was still alive. Do not think
that I came to destroy the law or the
prophets. Jesus's words. I did not come
to destroy but to fulfill. For surely I
say to you, till heaven and earth pass
away, one jot or one tit will by no
means pass from the law, till all is
fulfilled. Keith, what is a one jot or
one tit in in this this um context here?
What does it mean? Crossing your tees
and dotting your eyes. Okay. Well, there
you go. The smallest details, right?
Yeah. So, yeah. I mean, obviously
there's there's nothing about the law
that's changed because heaven and earth
hasn't passed away.
So, pretty easy. Yeah, pretty good
evidence right there. We're still here.
Um, and then, you know, the Bible is
full of verses, and there's only a few
that I can really put in this episode,
but it's full of verses that explain the
everlastingness of the law. And even
just logic can explain that, right? Like
again, how can Satan be considered a sin
sinner? And how could sin have existed
in heaven if there was no law? Because
the Bible says sin is a transgression of
the law. And because of the law, we know
sin. We see sin, right? So obviously
that already started in heaven. It was
there already. It has to be. Psalm 111
7-8 says, "The works of his hands are
verity and justice, and all his precepts
are sure. They stand fast forever and
ever, and are done in truth and
uprightness."
Psalm 119 says, "Concerning your
testimonies, I have known of all that
you have founded them forever."
Revelation 14:12, "Will we be keeping
the law in the end time?" Yes. Here is
the patience of the saints. Here are
those who keep the commandments of God
and the faith of Jesus. So, this is a an
endtime people right before Jesus comes
who are keeping the commandments of God.
If they weren't if the law had done done
away with, they weren't wouldn't be
doing that. And then Jesus also said in
John 14:15, "If you love me, keep my
commandments." So I do want to point
out, and I think we've kind of discussed
this already around this table, that
keeping the law is not
burdensome. Keeping the law and God's
commandments is showing a love for God
because Jesus says, "If you love me,
keep my commandments." It's showing a
love for humanity. And like what's
actually bad about not killing, not
stealing, not committing adultery,
keeping the Sabbath. There's this beauty
in that, right? And David shows it all
throughout Psalm 119, which I encourage
anybody to read, that he's excited about
the law. He's he's like, "This is
beautiful, Lord. Just help me to
understand it more." That's how he's
writing about. And so Ephesians 2 says,
and we believe this as well, for by
grace you have been saved through faith,
not by works, lest anyone should boast.
For we are his workmanship, created in
Christ Jesus for God for good works,
which God prepared beforehand that we
should walk in them. So the way I see it
is and the way I understand Ephesians
here is keeping the commandments of God
is a result of Jesus coming into your
heart changing you and as a result of
that you will show fruits you will show
good works but it's a natural outflowing
of God's love it's a lot like a
relationship right when you um fall in
love with somebody you know there's
things that you want to do for them you
want to please them you want to um do
things that you know will make them
happy. And it's I mean everybody that's
like, you know, in that first honeymoon
stage of their relationship, it's like
you could ask for the moon and it'd be a
delight to give it to you, right? That
action shows something about the heart.
And when God's asking us to do certain
things, the demonstration of our love
for him should be these things over
here. But if you're looking at it like,
oh, why do I have to do that? I mean,
think back on your relationship. if if
your husband says, you know, I really
like it if you you know, keep the dishes
clean and stuff like that. You know, why
why do I have to keep that? I don't
care. You know, it's going to cause
tension and and um you know, that's why
it's like if we love God, we want to
honor him and do what he's asking us to
do. Yeah. On the flip side, if we find
that we are struggling with like, well,
I want to I I want to play Grand Theft
Auto 6 or whatever. I like those things.
Well, then we need to take inventory of
our own life. And there's a prayer in
Psalm 139:23 and 24 that I think is is
good for us to pray. Search me, oh God,
and know my heart. Try me and know my
anxieties. And see if there is any
wicked way in me and lead me in the way
everlasting. Open ourselves up to
saying, "Hey, God, do an inventory.
What's in my heart? What's in my soul?
What needs to change?" And be willing to
let him change you. Mhm. Instead of
saying instead of trying to hold on
those things that we know are not going
to be a part of heaven. The Bible's very
clear. Those evil things, they're not
part of heaven. So why do we want them
now? Yeah. I remember I had a pastor sit
next to me one time after hearing um one
of the presentations on superheroes and
he he was just like, "Well, I don't
believe anything you say because I'm
going to just watch all these movies and
stuff like this and it's not going to
change my views of God." And I just had
this thought pop in my head and um say
just, you know, ask him about what if
God asked you to change? What if God
asked you to stop watching those
particular movies or something like
this? And he sat and he thought about it
for a second. He said, "I'd still watch
them." So I was kind of like, "Well,
your problem necessarily isn't the
movies. That's a symptom or that's just
an outward of of an inward problem,
which is like if God asks you to do
something, would you want to honor
that?" If God says, "Hey, don't don't
don't play with sorcery." Should we play
with sorcery? I mean this is this is
where the rubber meets the road of like
you know God is that there he is asking
something from his people and his
followers to show the demonstration of
of of your love and and the outworking
of the Holy Spirit in your life and um
and I think that if you just have that
attitude well I love it I want to do it
and I really don't care if God's asking
me I'm going to do it anyway that spirit
is not going to be that's the problem
that's the problem yeah it's a heart
problem. And that's a good thing that
Jesus is the best heart surgeon that's
ever been on earth. He'll give you a new
heart. Exactly. Amen. And then also
James 2 says, "For as the body without
the spirit is dead, so faith without
works is dead also." faith. If we say we
have faith in Jesus and not allow him to
work in us by faith to change our hearts
and do something about it, when he
convicts us, say, "Hey, Denique, I need
you to change this." And I say, "Well, I
have faith in Jesus." Well, no, but
Lord, you convicted me. Help me, Lord,
to change this. And he and but I have to
go out and do it. If you don't have that
combination, it's dead. There is no
faith. A form of godliness, but denying
the power. Exactly. The power is to make
the change. Exactly. Anybody could claim
they could bench press 400 lb,
but it's only the people that can
demonstrate it, that can actually do it.
Yeah. Right. That's right. So, this is
this is how I, you know, correlate some
of those things. Anybody can say, "Oh, I
got faith."
How do you know?
You demonstrate it. Yeah. You say you
love you love your spouse. Was that the
end of that conversation or is there
like an actual actions that demonstrate
your love for that person? Well, and
it's the same in a marriage like you
said, our marriage is the closest thing
to our relationship with God, a close
thing we have on this earth to our
relationship with God. And in the Bible,
um the marriage is actually even a
symbol of our relationship with the
Lord.
So if we are married and we are married,
you're in a
relationship, how would it be if we just
went and took the marriage vows? So like
saying, "I'm a Christian. I have faith
in Jesus, but then we broke all of our
marriage covenant and commandments,
right? Like I'm just going to sleep
around. I'm going to commit adultery and
I'm going to not love my spouse and I'm
just going to um, you know, not care and
and if my spouse says that really hurts,
like I don't care. I can do whatever I
want. Isn't that the same thing as
saying, well, I have faith in Jesus, but
then like I'm going to just do all these
things and not worry about what God is
asking of me. You know, it's it's it
gets really sticky there. Um, so James 2
also says, oh, that was the wrong
reference right there. I I'll skip that.
Um, and and you know what we have to see
then is the fruits of the spirit. love,
joy, peace, longsuffering, kindness,
goodness, faithfulness, gentleness,
self-control. Against such there is no
law. Again, then against such there is
no no condemnation because we are in
Christ Jesus. It's all about love. Jesus
is about love. The commandments are
about love. And the opposite of that is
sin, right? And that is the kind of
stuff that we are seeing in games like
Grand Theft Auto, right? It's the exact
opposite of the fruits of the spirit.
Psalm 119, J David goes into um the his
love for God's commandments over and
over and over again. Again, highly
encourage you to check it out for
yourself, but here are a couple of
verses where he specifically talks about
it. He's like he's like he's longing.
Literally, he uses those words longing
for God's law. I mean, that's a big word
to use for something if it it's so
insignificant, which it's not. Going
back to the
question that the person asked, and I
thought it was such a genuine question.
I'm a newborn
Christian. Can I play Grand Theft Auto?
Is it a sin? You know, somebody said,
"No, you're actually not committing any
sin, so
no." Well, again, what is sin is the
breaking of God's commandments, right?
Yeah. Who defines it? That's the
important part. Are we defining it? Or
is God defining it? Because it it
doesn't matter what I say. I'm just a
human being. But if God says it now, it
matters. So if God's the one defining
sin, then we can't just come along as
human beings and say, "Nah, that's not
that doesn't matter." Mhm. Because now
I'm putting myself in the position of
God. God's love is for everyone. And the
commandments are about loving God and
loving man. And you can't just check
some boxes and keep the commandments and
make it to heaven. But also the opposite
goes. You can't not, you know, keep the
commandments and just be like, I'm just
going to do whatever and claim the name
of Jesus, but then I'm all good. when
the Bible has a balance like you have to
study the entire book of the Bible and
put pieces together, you know, not
taking one scripture and and and basic
idea off of that, but take the whole
Bible and if you read the whole Bible,
there is a balance between, hey, love
Jesus, love God, but also Jesus saying,
if you love me, keep my commandments,
right? And it says in Matthew 7, there's
going to be many people who will call
the name and say, Lord, Lord, I did all
these things. And Jesus like, I don't
know you, right? And that's what Jesus
wants to write the new covenant in our
hearts and transform us. G take the
heart of stone, give us a heart of
flesh, and when he says, "Go and sin no
more," he will give us the victory. Sin
no more. And so, Grand Theft Auto, you
know, I think um I hope that anybody who
watches this video will think about that
and think, you know what, I think Grand
Theft Auto is a sin. That would be my
conclusion. It's a sin here. Here's
something that I think is really good
practice to put into place as well. If
you're questioning something and you're
on the fence with something and and
you're like, "Well, I really can't give
you a straight answer. I don't know if
this is really good or bad." Right? We
should be asking God. Mhm. And giving
God permission to make you feel
uncomfortable. Don't let me sit down and
and enjoy this. You know, it's like that
little still small voice that sits on
your shoulder that that you know, you
know, when you're doing something that
you shouldn't be doing, right? Give God
that opportunity to say, "God, if you
don't want me to do this, then I give
you permission to change my heart."
Another way is uh just take the high
road. Yeah. How are you going to go
wrong? Yeah. M you know I know a couple
that in their marriage they decided
early on they
said whichever way either one of us
feels about it if if there's a higher
road that's the one we're going to take
no matter what. So even if they see it
differently they'll still take the
higher road so as to not cause offense
to the the other person and just to make
sure they're always on the straight and
narrow man. Yep. So, Grand Theft Auto,
yay or nay? I'm going to give it a no.
Two thumbs down. If you like this video,
like, subscribe, and hit the
notification bell so you know when we
launch new videos. And drop a comments
below, and we'll try to get back to you
if we can. What?
Say that again. No. No. I don't know
what to say.
[Music]